ALLEN ARCHULETA. ATKINS. EIGHT
PORGES BRADFORD BY ADAM CHIANG
DALLY DODD DOURADO ALGAE ON.
GONZALEZ GROWS HERTZBERG HELLO
HUESO HURTADO JACKSON JONES
LEYVA MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MONNING MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
PAN PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
SKINNER NUMBER BY CASKEY LEANER
WELL. A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MEMBERS TODAY WE HAVE SENATORS
BELL GLAZIER AND STERN
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WELCOME
SENATORS. THE SENATORS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE QUORUM
CALL FOR THE VOTE ON MEASURES
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO OUR FLAG. BY
SENATOR HILL. THANK YOU I'M-
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF YOU
COULD. GIVE ME A MOMENT TO DO
OUR PRAYER THIS MORNING. LOVING
AND MERCIFUL GOD TODAY WE THANK
YOU FOR THE DEDICATION AND THE
IN TORRANCE. OF OUR STAFF ARE
LEGISLATIVE FAMILY GREATER
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. WE ASK YOUR
BLESSING ON EACH ONE OF THEM AS
WE PRAY IN THE WORDS OF THE
POET JAN RICHARDSON. BLESSED
ARE YOU. WHO BEAR THE LIGHT IN
UNBEARABLE TIMES TESTIFY TO ITS
IN TORRANCE AND AMID THE ON
DURABLE WHO BEAR WITNESS TO ITS
PERSISTENCE WHEN EVERYTHING IS
IN SHADOW AND GRIEF. BLESSED
ARE YOU IN WHOM THE LIGHT LIVES
IN WHOM THE BRIGHTNESS BLAZES.
YOUR HEART A CHAPEL ON ALTAR
WHERE IN THE DEEPEST NIGHT CAN
BE SEEN THE FIRE THAT SHINES
FORTH IN YOU IN ON ACCOUNTABLE
FACE. IN STUBBORN HOPE IN LOVE
THAT ILLUMINATES EVERY BROKEN
THING IT FINDS AHMED. PLEASE
JOIN ME AS WE SALUTE OUR FLAG.
BUT. S. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MOVING ONTO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR AUGUST TENTH
THROUGH AUGUST FOURTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE APPROVED
AS CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE
CLERK. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO
AA WILL BE WAIVED FOR THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB. TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO ON
TODAY WITHOUT FOUR DAYS NOTICE
ON THE DAILY FILE. YEAH. MOST
SENATE SENATOR RUBIO FOR WHAT
PURPOSE DO YOU RISE. THANK YOU
PRESIDENT UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS I WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE FILE ITEM. ONE TWO NINE
EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER EGGMAN FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
OF AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL. TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN
NINETY THREE WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS FIFTEEN OH
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS AND
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY OH FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS. MOVING ON
MEMBERS TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SENATOR WELLS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT IS A CONFIRMATION
OF TINA JOHNSON HALL PRESTON
PRINCE AND DELYLAH SELECT- TO
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
REBEKAH FOSTER PORTION
MIDDLETON ELIZABETH MORRIS AND
DAVE RAN TO THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP CORPORATION
BOARD OF DIRECTORS. IN Z. A'S
ZAPPER TO THE STATE MINING AND
GEOLOGY BOARD THESE APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY NINTH
OF JULY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE BILLS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION IT OR DEBATE ON
THESE APPOINTMENTS. SEEING NONE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES. HI
FORGES. BRADFORD. I CUT BY ADAM
I CHIANG. DALLY FIVE DODD. FIVE
TORONTO I GALGIANI HI GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO HI TADO I JACKSON HI
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL I MONEY.
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE FIVE
NIELSEN I PAN FIVE PORTANTINO
FIVE ROTH. HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER.
HI I'M BURKE HI MY COUNTY FIVE
WIENER HI WILK. HI. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES I
CHIANG. MELENDEZ MONNING.
SENATOR WORKS MOVE MOVES A CALL
BUILDING ITEM TO I ON TO ITEM
NUMBER NINE SENATOR WELLS.
THANK YOU MEMBERS NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE WHICH IS
THE CONFIRMATION OF REMOTE
BARKET RENEWED TOMARI AND DAVID
AND ALLOWED TO THE CALIFORNIA
EXPOSITION AND STATE FAIR BOARD
OF DIRECTORS. JONATHAN MOSCONI
TO THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
STEPHANIE AS CYNTHIA MARTIN AND
DAVID SIMMONS TO THE COMMISSION
A TEACHER CREDENTIALING AND R.
MICHAEL LEVINE NAY AND DOUGLAS
WEEKLY TO THE COMMISSION ON
DISABILITY ACCESS THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON JULY TWENTY
NINTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SENATE SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PRESERVATION OF ADEQUATE VOICE
RENEWED TOMARI SHE IS JUST AN
EXTRAORDINARY TALENT HARD
WORKER. VERY BRIGHT ALWAYS
FOLLOW THROUGH HER HUSBAND I'M
NOT SO SURE ABOUT BUT I STAND
STRONG SUPPORT OF HER
NOMINATION. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU I DON'T SEE THE NAME
UP THERE BUT I KNOW YOU JUST
MENTION THAT VERBALLY I WANNA
STAND IN SUPPORT OF DAVID L.
SIMMONS TO THE COMMISSION DAVID
AT THE DISTANT DISTINGUISHED
EDUCATOR AND ADMINISTRATOR IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IS
CURRENTLY SERVING AS THE
ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES FOR THE COLLINA
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT HAVING A
MEMBER OF THE C. D. C. WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCE HIRING AND STAFFING
SCHOOLS WILL PROVIDE A RESOURCE
CURRENTLY LACKING AND THE
COMMISSION I WAS PROUD TO OFFER
THIS BILL LAST YEAR AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ALSO ASK FOR YOUR
I. BUILD AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SENATOR MOORLACH. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF RENEWED AMARI- BUT I
ALSO THINK THAT AS A BODY WE
NEED TO BE REAL CAREFUL ABOUT
CALYX BIO IN THE STATE OF FAIR
GROUNDS- THERE CLOSE THIS YEAR-
THEY'VE- BEEN HANDLING ALL
KINDS OF EMERGENCY AND HOMELESS
PROJECTS AND I DO NOT BELIEVE
WE HAVE A BUDGET LINE ITEM FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE FAIR SO-
THE POSITION OF APPOINTMENT FOR
MISTER MARI IS GONNA BE
MEANINGLESS IF WE DO NOT
PROVIDE- THE ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR THIS EXCELLENT RESOURCE TO
CONTINUE. WITH THAT THANK YOU
MATTER PRESIDENT. SENATOR PENN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF BOTH THREE
THAT THE MARI AND- REMOTE.
MARKET FOR THE RE APPOINTMENTS
TO THE TELEX BO BOARD- CAL EXPO
IS AN IMPORTANT RESOURCE FOR
OUR COMMUNITY. AND OUR STATE
BECAUSE OF THE TOUGH IN THE
STAGING AREA FOR EMERGENCY
ACTIVITIES- DURING TELEVISION
WE HAVE USED IT AS A PLACE TO.
HOUSE PEOPLE WHO ARE HOMELESS
TO ME EVEN BE POSITIVE SO WE
CAN PROPERLY ISOLATE THEM TO DO
TESTING. BUT RIGHT NOW WE
BASICALLY. CALLING CAL EXPO TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES THROUGH
ACTIVITIES LIKE A STATE FAIR
AND OTHERS WHICH OF COURSE NOT
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. SO
CERTAINLY I THINK THESE
APPOINTMENTS UNDERSCORE THE
ROLE THE STATE HAS. WITH THE
CALICO WHICH IS A STATE AGENCY.
ANDSO- CERTAINLY- STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THESE APPOINTMENTS.
BUT WE SHOULD ALSO LISTENTO
OUR THE POINT IS THAT WE'RE
CONFIRMING. IN TERMS OF- THEIR
DIRECTION THAT DAY GIVING TO US
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO TO
SUPPORT. OUR THESE VERY VITAL
SERVICES AND- A BIRD DISASTER
SUPPORT ACTUALLY THAT- CAL EXPO
IS PERFORMING SO. I SPEAK IN
FAVOR THANK YOU. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
IT SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES I PORGES I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALLY I DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
GALGIANI. I GONZALEZ FIVE GROSS.
HI HERTZBERG FIVE HELLO AYE
HUESO. I HER TADO FIVE JACKSON.
I JONES I LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL FIVE
MONNING. MORLOCK. FIVE ZERO I
NIELSEN. I PAN. HI PORTANTINO
I. ROSS HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER.
HI AMBERG I Y. CASKEY I WIENER.
I WILK HI. SENATOR WILL TO MOVE
THE CALL MOVING ON TO ITEM
NUMBER TEN SENATOR WILK THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN IS CONFIRMATION AND
CHRISTOFFEL VELASQUEZ IS
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT MR VELASQUEZ BRINGS
EXTENSIVE EXPERIENCE IN HOUSING
POLICY IN THIS ROLE HE WAS
PREVIOUSLY SENIOR DIRECTOR AT
THE URBAN INSTITUTE IN PRIOR TO
THAT HE SERVED AS ASSISTANT
SECRETARY AT THE US DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND URBAN
DEVELOPMENT HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
FIFTH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVALS. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
AYE BATES. FIVE PORGES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I CHIANG.
DALLY I DODD I TORONTO I
GALGIANI I GONZALEZ HI GROSS.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI HUESO I
HER TADO HI JACKSON. I JONES I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S. I
MITCHELL. I MONNING. MORLOCK
MURROW. NIELSEN I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO
I SKINNER. HI NUMBER FIVE
CASSIE I WINNER AYE WILK AYE
CENTER WILL MOVE THE CALL.
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SENATOR WILK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER LET
IS A CONFIRMATION OF KIMBERLY
KURT MEYER AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MISS
KIRK MAIER WAS EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT THE MEDICAL BOARD
AND SHE HAS SPENT HER ENTIRE
PROFESSIONAL CAREER WORKING AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS WERE AT BOARDS WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT. SHE WAS
APPROVED ON UNIT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. THING NINE AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS HI PLEASE
HI GORGEOUS I BRADFORD I CAN BY
ADAM I CHIANG DALLY. I DODD HI
TORONTO HI GALGIANI I GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG I
TELL FIVE HUESO HI HER TADO.
HER TADO FIVE JACKSON. I JONES.
FIVE FIVE LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL.
FIVE MONEY MORLOCK I MORRELL I
NIELSEN HI PAN HI PORTANTINO I
ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER. I
NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI HI WIENER.
I WILK HI. HIGHS THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE PRIME MINISTER IN FIRM.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SENATOR
WORKS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE IS A
CONFIRMATION OF VALDO SINI YES
IT DIRECTOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FESTIVE PESTICIDE REGULATION
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT MR
DOLE SINI WAS SERVING AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ACTING DIRECTOR
ALSO DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
AGRICULTURE AT THE CALIFORNIA
E. P. A. HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST FIFTH
ON INANIMATE FIVE OH VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT.
SAYING NINE ADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BATES. I
PORGES I BRADFORD. I HAVE A
ADAM FIVE CHIANG. DALLY FIVE
DODD. FIVE THEY'RE AWESOME HI
GALGIANI HI GONZALEZ HI GROSS.
HI HERTZBERG. I HILL HI HUESO.
I HER TADO HI JACKSON. I JONES
I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
I MITCHELL HI FIVE MONEY.
MORLOCK HI HELLO. FIVE NIELSEN
I PAN FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROTH
AYE RUBIO HI SKINNER. I NUMBER
HI WHAT KASKY I WIENER AYE WILK.
HI HIGHS THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK
TO. MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. SENATOR MELENDEZ THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- PURSUANT
TO SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT I
MAKING A MOTION TO WITHDRAW ACR
NINETY THREE FROM THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE AND BE BROUGHT
TO THE SENATE FLOOR SET THE
FULL SENATE COULD HAVE A
VIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT THE
MERITS OF THE GOVERNOR'S STATE
OF EMERGENCY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG. CENTERS
BUT A MAJORITY REST FOR A NO
VOTE. BUT I SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT S. J.
R. NINETY THREE IS A VERY
IMPORTANT POLICY DEBATE THAT I
THINK WE OUGHT TO BE HAVING AN
COMMITTEE AND THEN EVENTUALLY
ON THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
MAJORITY LEADERLEADER
HERTZBERG ASKED FOR NO. SENATOR
JOHN TO ASK FOR A NIGHT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN NO
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BATES. I
FORGES I BRADFORD NO CABALLERO
NO CHIANG. SALLY I DON NOTE TO
RAZA. NO GALGIANI NO GONZALEZ.
NO GROSS HI HERTZBERG. NO HILL
NO WAY SO NO PATADA NO JACKSON
NO JONES I LEYVA NO MCGUIRE. NO
MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL NO
MONNING MORLOCK. FIVE ZERO FIVE
NIELSEN. I PAN. NO PORTANTINO.
NO ROTH. NO RUBIO. NO SKINNER.
NO NUMBER OKAY NO WAY CASKEY.
NO WIENER NO WELL. FIVE I CAN
KNOWS TWENTY FIVE THE MOTION
FAILS. MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR AMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS PLEASE REMOVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES
OF CHATTERING AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU. SO ORDERED SENATOR
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG. YOUR
DO IT AGAIN WHAT ELSE UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. IF WE
ARE DONE WITH MAYES MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS ARE GOING TO MOVE
UP BACK TO THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE AND LEFT THE
CALL ON ITEMS EIGHT THROUGH
ELEVEN WILL START WITH ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CHIANG MELENDEZ AYE
MONNING. FIVE THIRTY FOUR
THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO THE
APARTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED ITEM
NUMBER NINE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BRADFORD I CHANGED.
MELENDEZ FIVE MONNING. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO. RIGHT I
MEAN THIRTY FIVE I CAN FOR SOME
REASON THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
DEPARTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED ITEM
NUMBER TEN. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FORGES CHIANG. GROSS I
MONNING. MORLOCK I MARROW. FIVE
THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
DEPARTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED. I
KNOW NUMBER. ELEVEN ITEM NUMBER
TEN ARE WE FINISHED OKAY. THANK
THAT CAN THAT INCLUDES A
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
ARE THERE ANY COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR SENATOR
SKINNER. YES PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WILL. CONVENE FOR THE
GERMAN AND THE ROOM WILL BE
ROOM ONE MOMENT. FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
CENTER SECONDS THE DESK IS
CLEAR MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH COLLEAGUES WELCOME BACK
FOURTEEN DAYS TO GO I WISH EACH
OF YOU LUCK THIS WEEK AS WE
CONTINUE OUR WORK AND THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION WILL BE THURSDAY
AUGUST TWENTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
AT NINE AM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU THE SENATE
DESK WILL BE THE SENATE WILL BE
IN RECESS UNTIL ALL LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS. IS RECEIVED AT THE
DESK. WE WILL RECONVENE ON
THURSDAY AT NINE AM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EVERYONE.